[Music]
we're gonna start getting messy now hot
cooking video part worker
[Music]
and have yet to meet a child who doesn't
adore past their past there is in short
supply I've never made my own though I
haven't got one of those machines
millions and millions of old Italian
grandmothers have been making it by hand
for years and it can't be that tough the
very least we could make me be some
tagliatelle or there's a lovely thing
called mal fat Oh which means badly made
and you bris roll out sheets and cut it
into sort of slightly random shapes what
sort of flower of you got past the
flower you've got to you photo oh that's
brilliant what I've got is plain flour
and a similar which is an Italian
semolina flour I've mixed 50/50 of that
the basic proportions you're going to
need are a hundred grams of flour to
each egg you've got 100 grams of flour
in the egg for each person I'm gonna
make it enough before so 400 grams of
flour weighed out into a ball gown and
four eggs make a well in the middle of
the flour add to its hefty pinch of salt
yeah and about a tablespoon of olive oil
egg the egg is a creeper Gaytan use your
hand like this yeah okay and use that to
sort of break up the eggs in the middle
you're gonna start getting messy now so
let's see how this goes here we go start
combining the flour into the eggs the
eggs feel really gross in your fingers I
think if you think that eggs feel gross
you're probably in the wrong business
you should be some kind of camera man
not a cook so keep turning it kneading
it and it will absorb all of that flour
okay I was needing on top of the scales
that is done just embrace it yeah keep
going
pretty soon the dope fiends your hands
for you I'm embracing it
embrace the no sweat honor idiot you're
a sweaty Norma like so we're gonna make
the one that looks awful yeah I'm not
fat so it means badly made terribly
terribly may think I'm well-qualified to
make that little ball low I would say
for everything out the ball onto the
table top and sooner or later you'll
have a clean table and a ball of silky
smooth world work dope and shoulders
like a bloody Viking weightlifter
feeling very silky it's not very silky
up from it it's not really sticking
together very well if I was your
grandmother and I spoke Italian I will
yell at you and say that's because
you're an EIN or slack boy and you
should be ashamed and I'm gonna come to
the phone your mum this is pot cooking
video part work out it's homework not
gonna get there I think there aren't
really any bits left on the table okay
back in the bowl cover it with cling
film so doesn't dry out yeah and we put
it in the bowl and put it in the fridge
for half an hour so I've watched enough
episodes of MasterChef in my time to
know that even with one of those fancy
machines one of the main criticisms
tends to be it wasn't thin enough so how
on earth are we gonna get it fit in a
with just a rolling pin so the main
thing is to not stop the pieces they're
too big there's nothing wrong with
cutting off smaller slices of it and
going at it in small ways but what's
funny about flour on the board but not
much and you just keep lifting it up
turning it over and turning it round
that way you stop it sticking so that's
already got to a stage where it's
feeling quite thin so the whole lineup
and I like that I can actually read my
screen through you faster so I got this
absolutely beautiful piece of kin it's a
double caster wheel cut two sheets of
this stuff you could put an egg in the
middle of one of them a raw egg have to
be a very fresh one so held together and
there's squee pot another sheet over the
top and squeeze the sides around and
you'd actually make
the early with an egg in the middle of
it and you poach it on certain the
fastest on the outside the egg is and
runny on the inside how do you know when
it's about the right thickness what is
the thickness of a very thin credit card
or quite a thick business card I wonder
whether it needs to be thinner again I'm
just thinking back to MasterChef
MasterChef my ass well they always say
is in danger you make it too thin the
only problem with that would be that it
might just sort of fall apart a bit of
the water but I don't that's gonna be a
problem
cut this into any old shapes you like
really slices squares diamonds for when
you call that that's perfect yeah that's
fine you got it man this is gonna take
about two minutes to cook a frying pan
on the stove get some olive oil good
glug of olive oil good on the holes but
make sure the waters at a rolling boil
do you touch the pasture at all and just
let just let it do its thing that's
perfect
and this I reckon is probably done it's
been two minutes into the whole list out
your pasta Jesus
and then put one more tablespoon of
pepper there chuckling sleep over that
yeah and what's happening is that the
water pass the water at oil and cheese
are breaking down into an almost like a
creamy sauce till the little bit of
water you've splashed in their balls off
combined the pasta water with your own
with the cheese and the pepper to make
cacio e pepe this is what it should look
like how's yours there the water is
pretty much gone off that's it service
oh yeah this is tasting ripe so it's the
easiest fastest simplest best way to
serve Pastner to give us well made I
think my kids are gonna love this
decision bloody delicious pasta I'll
give you that
I'm really impressed just using a
rolling pin but to those who say and
make him pass there is it's too much
enough fat that's all very well when the
supermarket shelves are full of the
stuff the only part of this I found
difficult really was the rolling but
then it was just a bit of elbow grease
really in normal times I wouldn't call
it an everyday pasta I certainly
wouldn't make this for the for a family
meal you always use dried packet pass
over that as any Italian will tell you
but what I think is nice about this is
once you get into the to thinking about
how it is you've made it
what thicknesses are good how the
flavors work together it's very pure and
very delicious you can do this if you're
stuck at home and you can't find any
pass in it and you don't have a machine
we've shown you can do it but faster
making bits dead easy we've got a couple
of businesses I think you try Oh try it
try it on there kind of thing and I've
yet to meet a child who doesn't adore
passed there this is superb would you
recognize it okay
what do you think
you